we don't do who he'd love then he
wouldn't exist I'm good it's like
nothing really matters to him right now
including me you gotta think real hard
about this do you have people they need
you no I'm taking the fight
Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who
infamously killed Apollo Creed appeared
today to issue a challenge to Adonis
Creed don't do this ain't got a choice
that's the same thing your father said
you died right here in my hands
that kid was raised in Haiti dangerous
he broke things in me that I never been
fixed ain't worth it
is not just us anymore today I want to
rewrite history if you want to fight
this man that's your business but don't
pretend this is about your father
this here is all about my wife
tonight pus-head it was fine without
their moms and down my lips
the tribulation
this won't be the end to me
are you
they can't because we're a team
[Music]
now you know what you fight before
well after brow you learn more about
yourself when I stepped in Henry it
wasn't all about me
[Music]
you